hi everyone
i
first just wanted to say it's such a
pleasure to be here and it's incredibly
inspiring to be in a room with
so many people that clyde loved
respected and learned from it's really
it's quite overwhelming to see
so i wanted to share with you today um
some thoughts from work that clyde did
uh sort of
earlier on
the pre-help years if you will some of
the stuff that shaped i think some of
his thinking
in the last decade or so and i actually
owe a huge debt to tom boyce because our
earlier conversations really uh
made me think quite a lot about
how clyde thought about the world
and indeed those of us who had the
privilege of experiencing clyde know
that he really saw the world as a
laboratory
and uh he thought about
real solutions real sorry problems in
the world as something that we could
learn from and in order to develop
solutions that would help find our way
forward and so what i'm going to do is
take you through a little tour of some
of the real world problems that he
sort of grappled with and that i think
really informed
his vision of biological embedding and
why he thought experiences
were so important in shaping
our health and development
so when i first met clyde he was heavily
engaged in trying to understand the
causes of the
rapid increase in adult deaths in
central and eastern europe following the
collapse of communism
and that crisis as many of you probably
know was so large that the mortality
rates were so high so suddenly that they
really rivaled the kinds of
death rates you would see in countries
that had
infectious disease epidemics except
there was no infectious disease epidemic
and so the task was to try to figure out
what was going on what was causing this
rapid surge in adult death
and so with other scholars including
michael marmot and martin boback and
others we bet we began to work uh to
hypothesize what could possibly explain
such rates of death and we observed a
couple of things that were going on this
top graph
shows genie coefficients of income
inequality across countries in central
and eastern europe across the years sort
of just proceeding and following
the collapse of communism there and the
bottom
table shows some measures of lack of
trust in institutions
whether or not you trusted
church and religious organizations
police civil service military and other
sort of formal sets of institutions
that were present in society and being
built
and
the patterns that emerged suggested that
the adult health crisis was probably a
function of a rapidly set of changing
societal institutions and that that
change that sort of economic and social
shock actually manifested itself through
stress processes uh and and and resulted
in these very high very dramatic uh
mortality rates
the complexities in this case were
tremendous first of all you had a whole
set of factors that were happening
things like income inequality things
like uh
trust in and in social institutions
there was variation across countries
there was variation across years and
clyde i it will always hit me deeply
very much saw
these variations as something not to be
controlled away but to be understood and
that's one of the things that i made
that made him a unique scientist i think
very often we seek to sort of isolate
causal factors
clyde saw that variation and that
complexity as part of what built a true
and rich
story and created deeper understandings
well
as the work we did on how societies
affect health continued
we turned our attention to a problem
much closer to home
not on the same scale as the central and
eastern european mortality crisis but
equally as perplexing
and and that was why were there
persistently high why was there
persistently higher life expectancy in
canada than in the united states why in
two such similar economically advanced
and stable nations would one have a
health advantage over uh the other and a
persistent health advantage at that um
and it turned out that health insurance
was not the answer the answer was not
that we have universal health care in
canada and they don't in the us and we
knew that from a mounting
set of studies and so what else could be
going on to explain that difference and
our work on this project was actually
one of the first times that i really saw
how meaningful and necessary cfar and
cfar programs were
to clyde's intellectual development and
then of course to my own
early on we took this very graph that
shows life expectancy differences of men
and women in the two countries to one of
the earliest successful societies
meetings and basically stood in front of
a room of brilliant scientists from
every discipline but our own
and asked what do you see in these
patterns what might explain
these kinds of patterns between two such
similar countries
and in the end through discourse and
reflection on prior literature we
arrived at a hypothesis that said it was
social spending and public policies that
that dictated the distribution of
resources that trumped things like
spending on health care that trumped
things like
economic growth which the u.s also
excelled at and actually even trumped
things like unemployment rates um and
that
help that sorry social spending and
public policies were responsible for
creating the kinds of environments the
schools the neighborhoods the family
environments that shaped
daily experiences and therefore
explained health and in clyde's eyes i
think the canada u.s story unlike the
sort of economic shock drastic story of
central and eastern europe was one where
you can see how graded differences in
societal conditions make graded
differences to health
that is it's not just at the extremes of
institutions and the extremes of
experiences that we start seeing
differences it's actually incremental as
neil pointed out in his uh presentation
of the gradients work
and one of the sort of propositions that
underlie our early work on canada u.s
comparisons is that the average
differences you see
may very well result from differences in
the socioeconomic gradients in health in
other words averages are born out of the
extent of inequality and we hypothesize
that because we thought experiences
shaped
these average differences and
experiences themselves are
socioeconomically determined that
socioeconomic gradients may also be
different
between canada and the us so as clyde
went the epigenetics direction over time
i stuck with this stuff
with other colleagues and have started
to produce a set of studies as have many
others
which look at the extent of difference
in socioeconomic inequalities in health
in canada and the u.s
this is a graph of racial disparities in
canada and the us amongst people who
were native born as opposed to being
immigrants
across a variety of health outcomes and
you can see the sort of lighter gray
graph bars are the us the darker ones
canada and on a lot but not all
of these health outcomes you can see the
u.s has a much higher
white non-white disparity than you find
in canada
recently we've also turned our attention
to trying to understand the relationship
between socioeconomic status and body
mass
and its variation across canada and the
u.s
and these are
results for differences by income
quintiles and one of the things we're
finding is that
the the nature of socioeconomic
disparities actually varies on several
scales the size of the gap matters but
so does the extent of the distribution
to which inequalities penetrate so
there's these multiple complex
differences across these two seemingly
similar economically advanced countries
that seem to really be at play
so all this to say there was a set of
world problems that i think clyde uh
processed as being examples and and
tales of what causes population health
patterns to be the way they are and i
think what layered on to that was his
biological understanding of the
sensitive periods in early life and he
put this kind of evidence together as
many have said he was able to put pieces
of the puzzle together in really amazing
ways and so
putting together the information about
societies and institutions with what he
knew about early child development and
human development and biological
embedding
we produced this uh framework for the
world health organizations in uh
commission on social determinants of
health which essentially says what i've
just sort of stated in more general
terms which is that
human development and human health are a
function
of the many environments that produce
everyday lived experiences and that
they're all interconnected in ways that
can create
inequalities in these experiences and
therefore inequalities and outcomes
or lead to more egalitarian distribution
of experiences and outcomes
with just a few seconds remaining i just
want to close by saying that
this work really
was
done in in in ways that are very
tried and true to clyde which is that
they were incredibly collaborative and
relied heavily on interpersonal
meetings and dialogues with a variety of
scientists and i think
clyde's sort of
way of working was this sort of
interpersonal
uh uh you know over time development of
ideas
and
he he found this incredibly stimulating
incredibly essential to his work
and
i i i would be remiss if i didn't say
this because i think in recent years he
had expressed some concerns about the
direction of major funding agencies
and and the inability to really sustain
these kinds of models and just how
important they are to the growth of
ideas of this nature of big ideas of
transdisciplinary ideas
and i think clyde showed by example how
much investments like that truly pay off
thanks
you